en 1935 l'économiste daniel ellsberg
travailler pour le pentagone le quartier
général de l'armée américaine il avait
pour mission de trouver des
justificatifs un prolongement de la
guerre du vietnam déjà démarré depuis
dix ans ellsberg apprend alors que deux
conseillers américains s'étaient fait
capturé et tué par les forces
vietnamiennes un colonel de l'armée
américaine avait même pu prendre des
photos de leur corps avec les traces de
chêne icebergs avaient trouvé le jackpot
ellsberg reçu les louanges que ses
supérieurs cependant à ce moment là il
était déjà opposé à la guerre du vietnam
mais surtout petit à petit j'espère que
ça en dit content que beaucoup d
informations qui suggérait un contrôle
du territoire par les forces américaines
étaient fabriquées de toutes pièces la
guerre était hors de contrôle est très
loin d'arriver à son terme cependant s
berck ne se sentait pas coupable ne se
sentait même pas responsables il
continua à travailler comme il le
faisait avec le soutien de ses
supérieurs pour justifier la poursuite
de la guerre qui toutefois l'élection
d'un nouveau président des états unis ne
changeait rien au contraire comme ses
prédécesseurs le président nixon
renforça la présence américaine au
vietnam et lança des opérations de
bombardement massif au final trop
faisant témoigner personnellement ayant
un oncle qui a été engagée dans la
guerre du vietnam et dont le fils aura
été mal formés handicapées mentalement
et des cdd sa trentaine s'en fut trop
pour s berg qui décida de révéler au
grand public toute l'atrocité de cette
guerre jusque-là classés secret défense
pendant de luz d'être surveillés et
harcelés sbq poursuivi en justice est
risqué cent quinze ans de prison en 1971
le new york times suivi d'autres
journaux publiaient enfin la révélation
stupéfiante desberg les pentagone mais
la vérité finit par éclater non les
états unis n'avaient pas le contrôle du
vietnam et oui ils violaient au
quotidien la convention de genève en
bombardant des civils et on torturant
des prisonniers de guerre des vagues de
protestation contre la guerre envahir
alors les villes américaines ellsberg
avait triomphé au doigt c'est
l'impression qu'on pouvait avoir pendant
les semaines qui suivirent la
publication des pentagone papers
mais comme elle berg explique lui-même
pour gagner la guerre de l'information
il ne suffit pas de révéler des
informations importantes est la guerre
de l'information dans laquelle elle berg
s'était engagé n'avait fait que
commencer et ce n'est qu'en 1974 qu'il
remportera suite à l'affairé watergate
qui conduisit à la démission de nixon
même s'il faudra attendre encore neuf
mois pour que les états unis capitule
enfin et mettre fin au massacre de 2
millions de vietnamiens
ce qu'on montre surtout l'histoire des
pays furze sait à quel point la guerre
de l'information est critique pour la
survenue le maintien et l'issue des
guerres physiques en particulier l'appel
à la haine envers une autre population
est un outil donc beaucoup de
gouvernements abusent aussi souvent pour
obtenir l'adhésion du peuple qui
gouvernent et ainsi accéder au pouvoir
mais de façon terrifiante ceci amplifie
aussi gravement le risque de violence
désastreuse on en a déjà parlé dans le
cas du myanmar et de l'ethiopie qui on
pourrait parler de l' influence très
dangereuse d'un certain murdoch sur les
médias anglophones j'aurais pu également
mentionné ce qui se passe actuellement
en france mais vu l'actualité je vous
propose d'étudier le cas des autorités
russes car il est de surcroît
particulièrement édifiant en effet les
médias russes ont tenté de dépeindre les
ukrainiens comme des rebelles à la solde
de l'otan et des états unis voulant
anéantir les communauté russophone puis
encore certaine désinformation vont
jusqu'à prétendre que le nazisme a
triomphé en ukraine et que la russie
étant seul à justifier a attaqué les
forces du craignent haine dans le but
est d'avoir l'adhésion du peuple russe
voir celui des peuples étrangers mais
comme on l'a vu avec les pentagon papers
révélé l'information n'est que la
première étape de la guerre de
l'information pour que l'information est
un impact majeur il est critique de la
diffuser massivement pour y arriver les
forces que désinformation russe repose
sur des médias étatiques capable de
monopoliser l'attention d'une grande
partie de la population russe en
particulier les populations plus âgées
mais par ailleurs ils peuvent exploiter
un travail qu'ils ont initiée depuis de
longues années en établissant des
réseaux de trolls et de compter un
succès comme la chaîne youtube russia
today selon guillaume chazot ancien
employé de google cette chaîne a été
recommandée 100 milliards de fois par
l'algorithme de youtube 100 milliards de
fois et on y trouve des vidéos aussi
trompeuse que des armes et l'ukraine la
russie ne pouvait pas ne pas agir encore
les anonymous déclare la cyberguerre au
gouvernement russe donnant ainsi
l'impression que le gouvernement russe
est une victime qui cherchent avant tout
la paix en particulier l'un des
objectifs de désinformation russe est
certainement la radicalisation du
mouvement séparatiste pro russe en
ukraine qui depuis 2014 semble alimenter
financièrement et en armement pour semer
le trouble et le chaos notamment dans le
don de basse et surtout pour maintenir
une critique permanente des autorités
ukrainiennes
le rôle central des algorithmes de
recommandations de cette guerre mondiale
de l'information semble de mieux en
mieux compris par les gouvernements que
ce soit du côté américain ou un sénateur
aux proches aux réseaux sociaux de
diffuser massivement des fossés
informations diffusées par les agences
russes ou du côté russe qui restreint
désormais l'accès à facebook et à
twitter depuis l'intérieur de la russie
après avoir poursuivi facebook en
justice deux mois avant l'invasion en
fait facebook obi déjà depuis des années
à des exigences des autorités russes et
plus exactement rose comme nador le
service fédéral pour la supervision des
communications des technologies de
l'information et des médias de masse les
propagandes russes semblent par ailleurs
abondamment et efficacement diffusée sur
les autres réseaux sociaux en
particulier tik tok et télégramme ici le
pdg de télégrammes un instant songé
modéré certains flux télégramme il a
vite fait marche arrière face à ce chaos
informationnel la commission européenne
a finalement riposté et s'est attaqué
frontalement à l'info garde des
autorités russes en bannissant les
dangereux médias étatiques spoutnik et
russia today y de l'union européenne
les autorités russes ont aussi bien
connus pour leur armée de trolls vous
sied appelé ferme de troy qui vont créer
toutes sortes d'activités fabriqué pour
induire les algorithmes de
recommandation en erreur m en tendance
des sujets favorable à l'or narratif est
noyé toutes les informations qui les
dérangent pétrole peuvent alors ensuite
massivement signaler des contenus qu'ils
veulent réduire au silence comme les
services open source et d'intelligence
que twitter a malencontreusement bloqués
peu de temps avant l'invasion russe ces
fermes de troll cherche aussi
constamment à diviser l'opinion publique
des démocraties pour les affaiblir
politiquement par exemple en contenant à
la chaîne des contenus polarisant mais
potentiellement parfaitement factuelle
ou en finançant la production de la
mésinformation comme cela a été révélé
notamment par d'ortie biology avec
l'objectif que l'interlocuteur des
autorités russes se sentent lui-même
menacé par l'opinion publique de son
propre pays enfin les fermes de troll
exploite aussi beaucoup le harcèlement
ou la menace pour décourager les
critiques à l'instar du président russe
en personne ou abusent de commentaire de
la forme je préférerais quand tu parlais
de maths pour détourner l'attention des
créateurs de contenu et découragé
apparaît de sujets sensibles
selon le prix nobel de la paix dimitri
borat of l'opinion publique russe est la
clé pour mettre fin non seulement au
conflit mais plus généralement velléités
des autorités russes malheureusement
toute protestation russe est illégale et
les protestants risque au moins la
prison pour exprimer leur désaccord avec
les décisions de leur gouvernement ceci
n'a toutefois pas freiner des milliers
de russes qui au péril de leur vie n'ont
pas hésité à défiler massivement en
russie pour appeler à la paix comme
daniel ellsberg ces femmes et ces hommes
sont de véritables héros prêt à se
sacrifier pour protéger des victimes
innocentes très loin de chez eux
incroyablement admiratif reconnaissant
et inspiré par la bienveillance
extraordinaire et par leur courage
incroyable selon l'organisation non
gouvernementale human rights watch ce
serait plus de 3000 protestants anti
d'hyères que les forces de police russe
aurait arrêté souvent en abusant de
violence qui parfois en se mettant à
plusieurs pour contrôler un unique
manifestants pacifistes des milliers
d'autres rues se sont mobilisés en ligne
en signant des pétitions pour montrer
que des corps de métier tout entier
s'opposent au gouvernement russe en
particulier des chercheurs des
ingénieurs et des enseignants selon ces
chiffres il y aurait même une pétition
qui aura récolté plus de 780 mille
signatures même si on va mettre un gros
bémol à ça parce qu'il ya certainement
beaucoup de faux comptes et peut-être
même beaucoup de faux compte parmi les
signataires je suis plus
particulièrement admiratif encore des
influenceurs qui en prenant publiquement
position pour la paix se mettent
clairement beaucoup plus à risque encore
comme le rappeur oxymoron ou comme les
joueurs de tennis andrei roublev et
danila medvedev quel héros mais les plus
courageux et les plus héroïques dans
cette affaire ce sont sans doute les 100
députés municipaux russes venant de
différentes villes à travers le pays qui
ont pris position publiquement contre la
guerre en signant de leur propre nom un
document affirmant entre autres que je
cite les espoirs d'une bonne vie en
russie s'effondre sous nos yeux oui car
malheureusement les sanctions ont frappé
le peuple pas les oligarques russes je
ne peux pas suffisamment souligné le
risque que ces personnes prennent si
poutine n'est pas déchu suite à la
guerre en ukraine ces héros de la nation
russe risque non seulement la prison
mais aussi et surtout l'attend tueur
comme l'ont subi d'autres opposants
avant eux ces gens sont de véritables
héros quoi qu'il en soit comme le prix
nobel de la paix dimitri mouratov le
président ukrainien volodimir zelensky
semble penser lui aussi que l'opinion
publique russe est la clef de l'enjeu
ukrainien peu de temps après les
premiers bombardements
c'est en effet au peuple russe que le
président zelensky a choisi de
s'adresser
ron nagle
quatre élus du congrès
tandis qu'à l'ouest green 4 bobigny pour
thalys ou bi dit von braun ya zina je
dois être meilleur et chimie pacage pas
réussi comme delvigne n'engage venir
récit d'un niveau vide et annie dany
boon est brave de
après neuf tours jetons logement astana
800 paquets me pose est est-ce le rocker
bruce iii par sinik rouge radi mire ça y
est ça à stoneham et passe maintenant à
nos sièges restent au stade
a dit le russe qui va aisni ya trop de
crédit aux batteries tina cet
avis est le cas à trois grandes zones à
risque et pirate jack the war
je souhaite de tout coeur que via
télégramme d'autres réseaux sociaux son
message sera délivré un maximum de
russes et pour cela il va falloir
réussir à contourner les services de
désinformation des autorités russes
jusque-là actualité oblige je me suis
beaucoup arrêté sur le cas de la russie
cependant il faut bien se rendre compte
que la guerre mondiale de l'information
a déjà a très largement commencé à
travers le monde notamment sur internet
il façon très préoccupante celle ci fait
intervenir des acteurs très dangereux
venant des quatre coins du monde y
compris aux portes de l'europe de
nombreux dirigeants parfois qualifiés de
dictateurs exploiter des outils de
désinformation sophistiqués pour
affaiblir ou manipuler les démocraties
d'erdogan en turquie à loukachenko en
biélorussie en passant par mohammed vi
au maroc où il a mal hier en azerbaïdjan
pour ne nommer qu'eux parmi tant
d'autres ces dirigeants abusent de ferme
de troll pour protéger leur pouvoir par
exemple en harcelant les mouvements de
droits de l'homme dans leur pays et leur
diaspora en produisant parfois même des
dix fake pornographiques pour
déstabiliser les journalistes ou en
fabriquant des scandales de toutes
pièces en éliminant l'opposition
journalistique ces pays se prémunissent
de whistleblowers comme daniel ellsberg
et peuvent plus facilement contrôlé le
régime informationnel de leur peuple à
l'instar de la russie actuellement ces
états autoritaires ont désormais de
puissants outils de désinformation en
ligne comme la chaîne chauve tv
contrôlée par le gouvernement marocain
qui a été mentionné partinico buhari clr
l'une de plus importantes conférences
mondiales en intelligence artificielle
et oui je parle de la même taille
globaux que google avait viré moins d'un
mois après le début de la guerre en
ethiopie alors même qu'elle lançait un
projet sur les appels génocide qui ont
lieu dans la région en plus de la
propagande de nombreux et à exploiter
des armes de surveillance redoutablement
efficace comme logiciel espion pegasus
capable d'infiltrer un téléphone sans
que la victime ne cliquent sur aucun
bouton à l'instar encore une fois de
daniel ellsberg de nombreux journalistes
ont ainsi été attaqués par des
gouvernements autoritaires mais ce n'est
pas tout selon amnesty international
comme le super milliardaire greffe pesos
le président de la république française
emmanuel macron aurait lui aussi été
victime d'une attaque pegasus commandité
par le gouvernement marocain étrangement
toutefois le gouvernement français n'a
pas réagi à cette attaque supposer ce
qui pourrait signifier qu'il doute de
l'attak ou peut être plus probablement
encore qu'ils en ont été effectivement
victime mais ne veulent pas fâché le
gouvernement marocain car celui ci
aurait ainsi accès à des données très
106 bhl de façon très préoccupante des
forces des étrangères d'infos guerre
semble avoir ainsi réussi à infiltrer et
à corrompre les démocraties comme le
révèle le documentaire la caviar
connexion de la chaîne arte en
particulier de parlementaires européens
l'italien luca volonté et l'allemand uwe
douars de link nerfs ou étaient
condamnés pour corruption de façon
troublante peut-être à cause de ce
lobbying les gouvernements démocratiques
se sont engagés dans du trafic d'armes
avec des gouvernements étrangers
pourtant bien connus pour leurs
activités d'un fauve guerre par exemple
la france a récemment vendu 80 rafale
des avions de combat aux émirats arabes
unis alors même que le gouvernement de
ce pays est connu pour son pegasus
locale appelée dark matters et qu'ils
mènent des opérations de drones autonome
en ethiopie d'ailleurs le budget
militaire des émirats arabes unis dont
l'économie repose en partie sur une
forme d' esclavage moderne ce budget
militaire est supérieur à celui de
l'espagne est elle à moitié de celui de
la france pour une population huit fois
moins nombreuses de façon très
préoccupante bonne partie de ces
investissements massifs permet
probablement le développement de drones
autonome de guerre y compris dans des
pays aux régimes et aux institutions
moins fiables comme l'azerbaïdjan et le
maroc qui semble avoir tous deux fait
usage que ces nouvelles armes de guerre
peut-être plus surprenant encore la
turquie dispose non seulement de drones
elle en exporte même désormais de façon
terrifiante dans les années à venir ces
nouvelles armes de guerre dévastatrice
pourrait se démocratiser et être ainsi à
la portée de milliers voire de millions
d'organisations différentes
le marché de ces armes pour bientôt être
complètement hors de contrôle de toute
autorité et des attaques dévastatrices
pourrait alors survenir n'importe où
nous nous dirigeons peut-être vers un
futur où un grand nombre d'individus
différents venant des quatre coins du
monde pour tous des planchers un
cataclysme monumentale en écrivant une
poignée de commandes seulement sur un
ordinateur
la guerre mondiale de l'info on n'a rien
de nouveau depuis les débuts de la
guerre les dirigeants du mobiliser leur
peuple pour prendre les armes à l'aide
de mots ou d'image en cela une nouvelle
technologie n'ont fait que déplacer le
problème les champs de bataille au
prospectus des prospectus à la radio le
radio à la télévision il doit télévision
à internet l'info guerre là rien de
nouveau là toujours été critique pour
initier ou arrêter des guerres et
l'opinion publique a souvent été le
principal frein aux élans expansionniste
de certains dictateurs comme par le
passé il nous faut donc y occuper le
terrain pour déconstruire les narratif
trompeur révéler les atrocités de cayres
et appelé à une paix si rare dans
l'histoire de l'humanité en fait cela
est sans doute devenu plus urgent que
jamais en effet parce que les armes de
guerre disponibles sont de plus en plus
terrifiante l'est devenue critique de
prendre beaucoup plus soin de la qualité
de l'information diffusée à travers tous
les canaux et de ne plus se contenter du
laisser-faire désastreux du contrôle
autoritaire terrifiant de l'information
qui aura dominé le monde depuis des
millénaires la guerre de l'information
déterminera le futur de l'humanité en
particulier dans son livre fascinant
ouch angie apple le juriste et chercheur
katzenstein souligne à quel point cette
info guerre peut conduire des
soulèvements populaires spectaculaire et
souvent inattendues y compris par les
experts notamment lorsque peu de gens ou
une compréhension correcte de ce que
leur père pense selon sunstein la clé de
tels soulèvements est un phénomène de
réaction en chaîne ou la popularité
d'une contestation peut soudainement
convaincre une grande fraction de la
population de prendre part à la
contestation à leur tour et enfin dire
ce qu'ils pensent vraiment y compris
lorsque ceux ci se fait au péril de leur
vie
sachant cela dans le cadre de la guerre
en ukraine en particulier il semble
absolument critique d'encourager les
protestations russes en les partageant
massivement sur les réseaux sociaux et
en les justifiant avec des informations
de qualité en particulier sur ce qui se
passe actuellement en ukraine souvenez
vous beaucoup de russes pensent qu'il
n'y a pas eu d' invasion russe et que
l'armée russe est simplement venu
apporter son aide aux séparatistes pro
russes pour stabiliser des régions
instables en particulier selon les
derniers chiffres que j'ai pu trouver le
président russe est encore
incroyablement populaire dans l'opinion
publique russe ce qui rend sa contestées
encore très difficile combattre la
désinformation russe est alors critique
pour que cette opinion publique jugent
les autorités russes avec la meilleure
information possible et pour cela il est
nécessaire d'identifier les contenus
informationnels de qualité et vous
pouvez aider en comparant la qualité de
différentes vidéos par exemple sur le
sujet de l'ukraine via la plateforme
tournesol dont c'est vraiment l'objectif
dans cette guerre de l'information nous
avons tous un rôle à jouer en
particulier il semble crucial que les
influenceurs mesure l'ampleur de la
charge morale qui les incombe leur
silence peut en particulier donné
l'impression que la crise en ukraine ne
mérite pas l'attention qu'elle reçoit
actuellement et ceux ci risquent de
normaliser le fait d'ignorer les
souffrances ukrainienne même quand ce
n'est pas l'objectif des influenceurs en
particulier ne faut pas imaginer que le
président poutine est aujourd'hui
intouchable comme tout dirigeant son
pouvoir dépend de la confiance de son
entourage en sa capacité à garder le
pouvoir si à cause de l'info guerre
l'entourage de vladimir poutine perd
confiance en son président alors des
bouleversements traces tic pourraient
survenir rapidement en fait poutine est
sans doute plus menacé que jamais et il
est d'autant plus important que ensemble
nous lui infligions l'offensive d'infos
guère décisive pour le faire tomber et
mettre fin à la guerre en ukraine et
ainsi atteindre d'une des plus grandes
menaces qui pèsent aujourd'hui sur la
paix pour le monde